Shang-Chi's conception and evolution in
Marvel Comics has often been mired in
controversy for one reason after another.
Here are some of the darkest moments from
the legend of Shang-Chi — also known
as Brother Hand, the Master of Kung Fu.
Those who study Shang-Chi's design from
the comics will no doubt notice that the
character came to bear more than a passing
resemblance to Bruce Lee in later years.
This was no coincidence. The character
was created by writer Steve Englehart and
artist Jim Starlin in 1972 to cash in on the
popularity of then-novel kung fu action films.
At first, Marvel Comics attempted to secure
the rights to 1972's cult classic show
"Kung Fu" to adapt into a comic series.
When they failed to get the rights,
Marvel acquired the comic book rights to Sax
Rohmer's infamous villain Dr. Fu Manchu. Thus,
Shang-Chi was initially introduced in Marvel
Comics as a previously unknown son of Fu Manchu.
Marvels' rights to the character, however, lapsed
with the cancellation of "Master of Kung Fu"
in the 80s. Later writers got around the issue
of not being able to use the name "Fu Manchu"
by retconning the name as an alias of Shang-Chi's
father, whose real name is Zheng Zu. The upcoming
live-action movie will keep to this new lore
by having Shang-Chi be the son of Zheng Zu.
While Shang-Chi is acknowledged to be the one
of the most honorable heroes in Marvel Comics,
that was not the path he was initially set
to follow. In the comics, Shang-Chi was born
in the Hunan province of China, where he was
trained in all forms of combat from a young age.
At first, Shang-Chi was completely
obedient to his father Fu Manchu's wishes,
believing him to be a benevolent
monarch. Little did Shang-Chi know
that his father was secretly one of the
great criminal masterminds of the world,
who had been training his son to be the
perfect assassin and killing machine.
"Son, it's time for you to
take your place by my side."
It was only when Shang-Chi took the life of
Dr. James Petrie in London as part of his
first mission on his father's behalf that he began
to be troubled by what he was being asked to do
in the name of peace. There Shang-Chi met his
father's nemesis, Sir Denis Nayland Smith,
who revealed the true nature of his
father's evil plans for world domination.
Aghast at the level of betrayal, Shang-Chi
turned on his father. He invaded Fu-Manchu's
lair and declared they were now enemies.
Over the years, Shang-Chi would make good
on his promise to his father by foiling his
plans for global domination time and again.
Shang-Chi was raised to believe in the
utmost importance of family and his
clan. Unfortunately, that belief
became the bane of his existence
once he declared war on his supervillain
father and the rest of his criminal family.
First among them was Midnight, Shang-Chi's
adopted brother. Although the two were not
related by blood, a solid friendship had existed
between Midnight and Shang-Chi from an early age.
That relationship came to an end once Fu
Manchu ordered Midnight to hunt down and
execute his rogue brother. Although Shang-Chi
pleaded with Midnight to renounce their father,
Shang-Chi was forced to
fight Midnight to the death.
Just as tragic was the relationship between
Shang-Chi and his half-sister, Fah Lo Suee, who
was later given the name Zheng Bao Yu after
the aforementioned rights issue over Fu Manchu.
Although there was no love lost between Fu
Manchu and his daughter, her desire to take
her father down was far from benevolent. Fah
Lo Suee led her own criminal organization,
and her plan was to use Shang-Chi to get Fu
Manchu out of the way so her own gang could
become the most powerful criminal organization
in the world. Once again, Shang-Chi was forced
to work against his family when he acted
against his sister as well as his father.
"You are a product of all who came
before you. The legacy of your family."
The tragedy of Shang-Chi's entire life has been
that while he is deeply committed to peace,
it could only be achieved through
the death of his once-beloved father,
the supervillain Fu Manchu. Or so Shang-Chi
believed. To that end, the 1974 comic series
"Master of Kung Fu" saw Shang-Chi track
down and seemingly leave Fu Manchu to die.
But the passing of Fu Manchu did not
bring Shang-Chi the relief he imagined.
After his father's death, Shang-Chi
embarked on a quest to save his mother,
who he imagined was being held against her will.
After a long search, he was able to finally
track her down in "Master of Kung Fu #123."
But there Shang-Chi discovered that
his mother was no captive at all,
but had truly loved Fu Manchu. His mother
renounced Shang-Chi for killing his father.
The young hero was given the moniker "False
son" by his former comrades and mother. The
mission that Shang-Chi believed would
free the world and his mother of his
father's evil failed to be the moment of
triumph he'd so desperately hoped for.
Shang-Chi discovered that letting his evil
father die was a more complicated act than
he had imagined. In 1983's "Master of Kung Fu
#125," Shang-Chi dealt with the loss of his family
and his own conflicted feelings by engaging
in the last rites of his father's funeral.
To fulfill his duties as a son, Shang-Chi
returned to Hunan to pay his last respects.
Even though he could not bear to
call Fu Manchu "honorable father,"
Shang-Chi nevertheless prayed that his
spirit would find peace. But his musings
were interrupted by demons both real and
imagined. Shang-Chi fled to other parts
of China in search of something that
would assuage his feelings of guilt.
Finally, after a twilight battle
against an assassin sent by his mother,
Shang-Chi drinks from his father's ceremonial cup
and is able to come to terms with his actions to
a certain extent. But that acceptance comes
at a price, as Shang-Chi renounces his past
as a crime fighter and settles down to
a simple life of farming and fishing.
Shang-Chi's personal history has always been
defined by the fact that he is the only child
of his supervillain father Fu Manchu who refused
to enter into a life of crime. After Shang-Chi
refused his father Fu Manchu's orders
to work for his criminal empire,
Moving Shadow was called upon to take
Shang-Chi's place at Fu Manchu's side.
Moving Shadow was yet another
half-brother to Shang-Chi,
and raised in a similarly brutal fashion to be
the perfect killing weapon. But while Shang-Chi
eventually came to see his father's
evil nature, Moving Shadow was blindly
subservient and completely willing to kill
his half-brother at their father's behest.
In the 2002 Marvel Max series, "Shang-Chi: Master
of Kung Fu," Moving Shadow came face to face with
Shang-Chi and tried hard to kill him. No matter
how much Shang-Chi exhorted him to see reason,
Moving Shadow was single-minded in his
desire to kill his brother. In the end,
Shang-Chi emerged the victor in their
battle, but refused to kill Moving Shadow.
But their father had no such qualms. Dismissing
Moving Shadow for having failed in his mission,
Fu Manchu personally launched a dagger
into his heart in front of Shang-Chi.
Shang-Chi has a long history of being part of
superhero teams, where his even-tempered nature
and top-notch fighting skills are invariably
assets. The 2006 series "Heroes for Hire" saw
Shang-Chi working alongside a host of allies,
including the insect-powered metahuman Humbug.
Humbug used to be Buchanan Mitty, an entomology
professor who turned to a life of crime to fund
his research. After constantly being foiled by
Spider-Man, Humbug decided to join the good guys,
which is how he came to be a part
of the super team Heroes for Hire.
In 2006's "Heroes for Hire" series, Humbug
gets manipulated by the alien overlord,
the Brood Queen. While under the influence
of the Queen, Mitty ends up betraying his
teammates to the Brood. While the team escapes the
Brood's prison, Shang-Chi rips Humbug's head off.
"Not a good time to lose one's head."
"Indeed."
"That's not the way to get ahead in life."
"No."
One of Shang-Chi's most memorable
crossovers occurred with Spider-Man
in 2011's "Spider-Island" event.
Shang-Chi finds himself infected
with something called the "spider virus,"
which grants him similar abilities to
Spider-Man. But along with the powers
come a series of disturbing nightmares
in which Shang-Chi sees himself transform into
a giant spider and attack innocent civilians.
The vision becomes a reality in "Spider Island:
Deadly Hands of Kung Fu," when Shang-Chi is called
in to help defeat the usually-heroic Bride of
Nine Spiders who is holding Iron Fist captive.
After freeing the other hero, Shang-Chi
discovers that Bride of Nine Spiders
is being controlled by the god Ai Apaec, who
has already captured the other Immortal Weapons.
While battling Ai Apaec, Shang-Chi's nightmare
comes to pass when the spider virus mutates him
into a giant spider-like creature. The
spider's instincts threaten to consume
Shang-Chi's psyche entirely. But a last-minute
assist from Iron Fist reminds the Master of
Kung Fu of his true nature, and Shang-Chi
is able to revert back to his true form.
Despite his youth, Shang-Chi's fighting
skills and serene nature have made him the
go-to guy for heroes looking to brush up their
skills. One such hero/anti-hero was Domino,
who sought Shang-Chi's help to become a better
fighter and generally a more even-tempered person.
In 2018's "Domino #4," Shang-Chi and Domino
engage in an intense round of sparring. At first
Shang-Chi is impatient with Domino's flighty
nature, but the two eventually grow closer,
even sharing a kiss a night club. Unfortunately,
things come to a head when the date is interrupted
by Shang Chi's enemies, on the orders of Domino's
enemy, Topaz. Shang-Chi helps Domino recover her
lost knowledge of her powers well enough
to take on their enemies single-handedly.
Eventually, Domino comes face-to-face with Topaz
herself. Despite Shang-Chi's pleas to show mercy,
Domino is unable to stop herself from killing
her archenemy. Disappointed with his pupil,
Shang-Chi dismisses Domino from his tutelage, and
their unlikely romantic relationship also ends.
Despite his extremely violent upbringing,
Shang-Chi has managed to stick to a pretty
pacifist path most of the time. But the Master
of Kung Fu has strayed from it from time to time,
like when he entered into a pact with the
literal Greek god of war, Ares himself.
The conflict arose in the backup stories of
2019's "Sword Master" when Ares and his legion
of Dragonborn soldiers got into a confrontation
with Shang-Chi and Sword Master. Ares wanted
to get his hands on Shang-chi's ally Lin
Lie's mystical sword, with which the God
of War intended to kill the kidnapper of his
son. Despite the misgivings of Sword Master,
Shang-Chi entered into a pact with Ares to aid
him with the sword and the retrieval of his son,
in return for the God of War's help
in finding Lin Lie's missing father.
Rather predictably, the deal soon goes south
as Ares, his son and Sword Master are forced
into a heated battle against Davi Naka, the Mother
Goddess of Madripoor. Although Shang-Chi is able
to temporarily placate the Goddess, the actions
of his former teammates, the Agents of Atlas,
lead to an all-out war between the surface city
of Pan and the underwater city of Atlantis.
Even after accomplishing his goal of
killing his father and his criminal cohort,
Shang-Chi was not rid of Zheng Zu's legacy.
In 2020's "Shang-Chi" series, the Master of Kung
Fu discovers that Zheng Zu's spirit chose him to
be the next Supreme Commander of the Five Weapons
Society. At first, Shang-Chi resists the calling,
even after coming into contact with
his newly discovered half-siblings,
Brother Sabre and Sister Dagger. But eventually,
he agrees to team up with his siblings.
Shang-Chi's intention is to rescue his long-lost
full sister, Shi-Hua, who is operating as the
supervillain Sister Hammer and attempting to
take control over the Five Weapons Society.
Eventually, Shang-Chi comes to accept that the
only way to stop the infighting is to accept his
role as the new Supreme Commander of the Five
Weapons. Although he vows to turn the society
into a force for good, his father's spirit visits
him upon his coronation, mockingly telling him,
"My throne suits you, my son. For you are
destined to become like me. Just. Like. Me."
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.